is it already sort of the start of not
showing your ideas
not playing your best openings and stuff
like that well i will say at this
point i don't know what my ideas are yet
so i'll just treat it as a normal game
[Music]
in very short our job is to
create an opening database for magnus to
use in the world champion match
the head of the team is magnus magnus
gives us some directions where we want
to to go and we try to fulfill these
kind of wishes
well here you're up against someone
who's probably also spent half a year
together with a team
we have so much time that we have to
create this big puzzle of options and
such our assumption is just that magnus
is the best player in the world and such
and
i mean it's not our job to
win games i mean
well
if we are the underdog we might try such
but we think magnus is the best player
in the world i think even by quite some
margin right so it's
well we more have to neutralize and make
sure he gets some territory where he can
show he's the best player
our role is to
make sure magnus gets gets
the ability to show he's the best player
in the world so it's well we shouldn't
make mistakes we shouldn't get him into
the kind of trouble but sort of
to have brilliant preparation for him to
win is not sort of we don't see it as a
necessity